more more MORE
[Music]
hello I'm Hannah Hart and this is edible
history the show where we make sure the
taste of history is no longer a mystery
today we'll be exploring the magic
behind the making of miso soup here's
the thing I love soup I want soup for
lunch I want soup for dinner I want soup
for breakfast if I could find a
contractor to install a soup fountain in
my house I would do it and one of my
all-time favorite soups is miso soup but
how far back does the history of this
super soup really go to give me the
scoop on this soup I'm talking with Jane
Matsumoto and Yoko Maya de lamb from the
japanese-american cultural and community
center in Los Angeles what's the overall
mission of the J ACCC it was established
in 1971 the first and second generation
Japanese Americans really dreamed of
finding a permanent place where our
cultural arts can be shared and kept for
generations to come
Yoko is one of our instructors that
really attracts a diverse crowd we
welcome those who really have an
interest in Japanese culture we have a
very broad range of people who take
classes at JCC si can you tell me about
the type of classes you teach I'm
teaching it
Japanese fermentation class how to make
a miso paste thing or its kimono class
how long do people in Japan been eating
miso soup it's actually probably start
from the miso paste and from China about
seven centuries it evolved from what it
was historically a much more rudimentary
soybean paste into a more sophisticated
product where it could be consumed by
warriors the samurai in the field and it
was a very flexible food product that
offered protein sources and very easy to
make so was the miso paste always used
a soup base or was it used as a paste
like you could just eat the past it
earlier people eat just the paste with a
rice bowl so cute tell me about the
evolution from a miso paste over rice
into having it as miso soup with water
over time Japanese are making stock also
we call it dashi and dissolving the miso
paste in the dashi really enhanced its
flavor so when do people start making
miso soup into more than just a broth
adding the green onion or the tofu it
probably evolved from the Edo period
there was a large population to support
people started to make a more robust
soup so help me understand it sounds
like this is a very time-consuming
process but as far as I can tell I can
make miso at home by opening a little
packet and pouring it in some water
right now the technology has advanced
where you can really wholesale make lots
and lots of miso but historically miso
was made by hand you would take the
beans the fermented beans and you would
literally have to hand grind it that
process has now evolved where it's
automated in a machine the thing that
hasn't changed though is the
fermentation time thank you so much for
being here and answering these questions
I am so excited to learn how to make
miso paste from you yes let's do it to
make sure my miso doesn't end up so so
Yoko is going to be joining me in the
kitchen
first the ingredients here oh can you
tell what is it uh I'm gonna guess it's
a dried soybean yes exactly but it
doesn't look like dried soybean I didn't
know they were so circular I have to
wash and a socket overnight and then
we're gonna cook oh that's a soybean I
know in love yes and how do you
determine it's cooked well or not use
your two fingers presses down oops so we
take it and then we squish it oh so
that's it that's it done soybean paste
so drained of water Wow
and the to this ball did this one yes
this is called ribbity ribbity ribbity
and this is called a foodie congee
Sudi Kogi yes ooh debauchee yes you
wanna try it yeah okay I assure you can
you hold it like that
mm-hmm and just to place up a little bit
and start it I love that it has these
edges these ridges you know every mortar
and pestle I've seen it's smooth uh-huh
but these ridges really help break it
apart yeah okay down and around
teamwork yes yes a little bit more yeah
they should have made the Warriors do
this it makes them strong yeah yeah I
know you're doing well oh thank you
very nice okay okay yes great okay I can
get it done so now we pull all the paste
off the side yeah and there's just a
wait a little bit
so next step it's a we're gonna use the
Koji ii the ingredients is natural
fungus this is the fungus yeah it's rice
rice it's moldy rice yeah
what can I touch it yeah you can't eat
it
really yes no way yeah okay that's good
Bon Appetit mmm sweet yes you know Bree
you know the the mold on top of three it
tastes exactly like that so to take this
koji into an additional Bochy okay so if
you have more in Kochi and it turned to
a more sweet so we're incorporating the
salt with our koji carrier because the
salt is lighter than Koji so you always
go salt goats at the bottom parts and
you pull it up - yes so these are our
two ingredients but then the third
ingredient that we end up using is
really
okay so you add it little by little
okay here we go use a hand and them
mixed together I took up my ring mm-hmm
sorry honey
started mixing oh it's good for
exfoliating the hands cooking water
sound little bit mm okay and let me help
you yeah a bit hon I didn't mix very
well we got a next step making of me so
mom thank you for saying I did a good
job yeah you know a student is only as
good as the teacher that's the truth
where do I get Koji I gotta get some
spores Oh you get enough from Japan I do
have it nice
we've made our miso Bo's what's next
okay so this is the fermentation pot
it's beautiful right yeah usually people
use in preserving a pickle and also the
miso mm-hmm so next we need to sanitize
yes and just a vodka vodka who uses
claws and the clean it's the whole thing
oh so we want to make sure it's very
clean so we only want one type of mold
no bacteria we are controlling this
environment and then you take it to one
ball mm-hmm
put it inside a pot and they use into
your knuckle and a place down like this
so you pack it down yes oh and then make
it that layer so that reason that we
press down because miso don't like it
the air oh yeah you really want to pack
it down
we think about our enemies we pack it
down yes okay so we put on that bleep we
set it aside to ferment mm-hmm good
night bye bye oh wow so it's been Oh
months really a year year yes
Wow you look great I know let's see how
it looks okay
ah whoa that smells like me so it's
Meisel ah this is amazing you can see
that the color has gotten so much darker
yeah
but then also the smell this smells
sweeter yes Wow
so what happens to make it go from this
to that fermentation at the end so we've
made our miso paste
now it's time to begin our broth okay so
let me introduce our ingredients here
the black thing is the konbu konbu yes
it's try to count ah smells like the
ocean all around here can State it's a
white powder it's not dust okay yeah
this is a umami flavor at the glutamic
acid on that Oh
so the white dust is what you're looking
for this is what brings out the umami so
so we need to soak kombu a while at
least in this 30 minutes and I usually
do it overnight good night and then it's
coming to here what is that so this is
the bonito yeah I heard it's the hardest
the fermentation food in whole word this
is putting the nito in bonito well it
looks like a piece of wood yes yes yes
Figgy good that so how do we get the
bonito from this to that you think it
these shaver so
Oh would you like to try I would like to
okay okay
and then let's open this bonito
look it is oh this is great
can we eat it yes sure delicious can I
tell you something I love bonito so much
because when you put it on food or
something warm it kind of dances yes
okay so let's check it the kombu here
it's already the flavor comes and I take
it out does anybody ever eat the kombu
we eat a kombu but today's not now and
then please put in all bonito all of it
yeah okay beautiful I turn on and the
way to enter the starting the boiling
again
oh so this ingredient is patience so you
like sports love to watching you you do
oh great
what's your favorite sport tennis tennis
that's the one yeah baseball to baseball
i watch yes I like baseball
yes yeah watch football mmm not really
that's cool oh I see some bubbles yes we
turn off and the one started boiling
because we don't want to a flavor or
gand and the wait and then wait we just
wait so do you play tennis yes oh I did
oh you did
so we've made our miso paste we're
waiting on the last bit of our dashi
next step soup our bonito has had some
time to rest yes what happens that so we
all do bonito take it out right now okay
the veneno doesn't look as pretty now
hmm bye-bye bonito next step is we're
gonna add it the miso paste on the
process oh yay hello darling smells so
good
so it's about the one scoop up tea a big
scoop yes great you don't want to strain
yourself can you mix a chopstick yes I
can after you added the miso paste don't
boil it too much so here is the white
blocks it's tofu high tofu so we just
like the cut
and let me add it and note boil just
keep it warm this is a koji yeah you can
take it out no can you eat it you can
eat it can I eat it uh-huh sure
where's she who new mold could taste so
great ha ha ha ha so we've added our
tofu and next we're adding more seaweed
seaweed yes it's called welcome in so
I'm gonna add it this way here and the
end is Negi green onion simply just ok
ok so we turn off of before the soup
starts boiling mmm and then we stir it
ah and to think we're eating just like
the ancient Japanese did yeah so the
last step is to sprinkle on some green
onion yeah little bit of green onion a
little bit of green onion and then we
finally get to eat
[Music]
I'm gonna truth let's do it here we go
right Yoko thank you
you thought I came on static your mouth
let's cut it what's going mmm no this
car it's good it's so good Wow what do
you think you're the I love it I love it
you can definitely taste that that umami
I am such a huge fan of miso soup and
I've never seen it made from scratch mmm
so this is this has been really special
for me so thank you so much thank you
for having me today
if you guys are in LA and you want to
learn how to make me so make sure you
check out the J ACCC and take one of
Yoko's classes and let us know in the
comments below if you would try making
miso soup at home speaking of at home
Yoko where do you keep your me so sick
thank you so much for watching this
episode of edible history people like
Yoko and Jane helped new generations
understand ancient cooking and
fermenting techniques and keep our
edible history alive
[Music]